[Musik]
meine Arsch wird
also genau genommen bin ich gerade auf
dem Klo ich habe no joke keinen Plan was
das hier für eine Toilette ist
allerdings hat die einfach mehr Funktion
als mein PC und der Sitz ist beheizt
also das hier das ist einfach warm ihr
fragt euch allerdings
Männer allerdings wahrscheinlich Mensch
Luca in welcher Stadt befindest du dich
gerade sehr logischerweise nicht einfach
sondern ein Hotelzimmer ich bin in
London
[Musik]
das Gegenteil von London Londorf
halt's Maul luca.de die fragt euch
wahrscheinlich eigentlich wird sich das
wahrscheinlich niemand Fragen allerdings
sagen nämlich der Grund warum ich gerade
hier bin äh das sind alles meine
Klamotten da Schlafzimmer
die Sache ist allerdings dass ich mich
gerade hin London befinde
[Applaus]
ich bin auf jeden Fall hier
dennoch haben wir eine wunderschöne Zeit
hier zwei Tage lang oder drei
oder zwei einfach blöd
hey
auf jeden Fall ist das ja also der
Eingang vom Hotelzimmer und dann geht
man als allererstes halt hier so rein
und wir haben erstmal einen
Kleiderschrank auf jeden Fall einfach
ein verdammtes Gästebad
ich habe keine Gäste aber zum Scheißen
ist ganz geil weil man sitzt dann quasi
hier ne wieder beheizter Toiletten sind
natürlich man kennt kann die Tür
aufmachen
ja gut man sieht so 5 cm von London und
übrigens ist das hier die Straße wo
diese ganzen teuren Leben sind so
Lewis Welten goki und so wenn man dann
allerdings unser Gästebad verlässt dann
kommt man hier in das arbeitswohnzimmer
wir haben jetzt einen Fernseher wie
gesagt beim Kirmes chillen die kann man
auch noch mal so ein bisschen gucken da
haben wir den Big Ben oder ansonsten
geht's dann hier noch rüber ins
Schlafzimmer das sieht auf jeden Fall
extrem aufgeräumt aus
meinen schönen kackaufnahme so gesehen
ich fühle mich wie dieser große Bär im
blauen Haus der man dann so bei seinen
Gästen anguckt
oh mein Gott der hat einfach mein
Traumjob ne Telefonzelle
Amerika Bus Stopp Mülleimer Mülleimer
Puste mich gerade fast überfahren hat
Akte Triumph alter und neuer Bus direkt
nebeneinander
Weg mit euch
keiner braucht die so schön ich wollte
ja mal hinziehen ich war ich habe auch
damals wir haben uns irgendwie so
Internatsschulen angeguckt oder so aber
dann hatten die alle so komische
uniformale und dann wäre ich fashion
bewusster Mensch mit 15 Jahren so nicht
mit mir
ich habe auch einfach vor acht Jahren
mal einen eintages-trip nach London
gemacht morgens sind geflogen Abend
zurückgeflogen mit einer Freundin leider
ein kleiner Ausschnitt
versteht ihr wegen kleiner Ausschnitt
also wir waren jetzt gerade hier shoppen
bei and
und ich bin ganz ehrlich eine
Monatsmiete für ein Paar Socken sehe ich
jetzt nicht von der LG mir zu kickt
keine Ahnung was da steht aber es
glitzert schön laufen wir zusammen
anderen Kaufhaus und bei der Route steht
dass es meist flach ist genauso wie mein
Humor der schwimmt genau so schnell wie
Sandra beim surfer-abzeichen Lokomotive
treffen
das war witzig weil da stand Schleich
und ich bin geschlichen
wir waren gerade hier bei fresco Baldi
keine Ahnung wir waren auf jeden Fall
geil Essen die hatten übelsten heiße
trüffelnudeln dann lass uns danach
aufgefallen die Kosten irgendwie 40 50
€, also übertrieben teuer alles wird
nachher eine Rechnung von keine Ahnung
100 € oder so um den Dreh und ich dachte
schon super für ein Mittagessen echt
schon habe ich kriegen die beiden
Geschäftsmänner neben uns Ihre Rechnung
2100 Euro
wenn man eine Straße überquert steht
hier in London immer so ein Look left
Look ride auf dem Boden aber ich gucke
mal in jede Richtung links rechts keine
Ahnung ich weiß nicht von wo können
Autos kommen hier
hey wie dumm Alter jetzt einfach einer
die Schuhe angemalt ich kann komplett ab
dicker ich habe gerade so unnormal Bock
auf chicken mit Reis
wer wer
bist du scheiß Taube nicht auf der Welt
brauche ich
bisher konnte ich euch nicht sagen warum
genau ich in London bin aber jetzt ist
ziemlich eindeutig
ich bin die Neue Queen also was mir auf
jeden Fall am krassesten in London
aufgefallen ist ist das Ampeln hier
irgendwie nur optional sind egal ob
Rot-Grün die fahren gehen kriechen
krabbeln
vergleicht mal diese Mülltonnen mit
Mülltonnen Deutschland
merkst Du selber
ich hätte gerne
und noch ein Scrabble noch ein Scrabble
was ihr gerade genüsslich eine nutzt
schlingt und da kommt eine scheiß Taube
die kein Mensch braucht für mich wie 'ne
Geographic hier gerade wenn man hier um
die Ecke läuft sieht man gleich den Weg
BAM
und
da wo ist er denn
eigentlich dumm
wow
ein bisschen eindrucksvoller und größer
in Erinnerung
und jetzt seht ihr mich im London Eye
[Musik]
das ist witzig weil ich bin in einem Ei
also ich kann dir niemals so einen Job
ausüben ne einfach weil mein Niveau ja
generell schon relativ weit oben ist
aber es dadurch noch mal ein Ticken wird
voll irre dass man aus dem London Ei
einfach den Big Ben sehen kann in London
aber ganz weit guckt sieht man einfach
sogar den Eiffelturm in Paris oh mein
Gott
der kann ja richtig gut blasen
das ist witzig nein Digger
hier sehen Sie wie moderne in Form vom
Chart muss mein Finger da in Form vom
Start auf Historie trifft eine England
Flagge und ein altes Gebäude was nicht
zuordnen kann und hier sehen Sie einen
Typen ihr könnt ab sofort turi-touren
durch London buchen auf der
Internetseite
dieses Gebäude heißt the Shard auf
Deutsch übersetzt die Scherbe warum weil
eine Scherbe Schafe und hier sehen Sie
zwei Schatz dementsprechend weil ich bin
auch ziemlich scharf
[Musik]
hier sehen Sie ein weiteres Beispiel für
die moderne die in einem kontrastrieren
Kontrast auf die Vergangenheit prallt
den Tower of London und die Tower Bridge
bitte für meine Touri Kenntnisse
abgegeben bei DHL und die Kacke ist hier
ist nur Hermes überall Essen Sneakers
Rettungswagen in London haben wirklich
7000 verschiedene Songs die die
abspielen können hört ihr das
hallo ich sitze im Zug von London zurück
nach Köln viele fragen sich
wahrscheinlich Luca warum fliegt ihr
nicht sondern fahr Zug einerseits
natürlich Umwelt aber es geht auch
tatsächlich deutlich schneller fährst
von London 2 Stunden nur nach Brüssel
und dann noch mal zwei Stunden von
Brüssel nach Köln dann fährst du 4
Stunden von London nach Köln das ist
einfach genauso lang wie von Köln nach
Berlin oder nach Hamburg das ist echt
ich genieße das Leben in vollen Zügen